when i have spent too much time in a
conference room that's generally when
things have gone awry
and when i go and spend time on the
factory floor really using
the cars um thinking about the rockets
it's like
that's where things have gone gone
better and things
appear to be going very well for elon
musk this year
spacex launched its first commercial
vehicle to put humans in orbit
tesla became the world's most valuable
automaker
and according to the bloomberg
billionaire index musk is now worth
about 145 billion dollars
making him the second richest person on
the planet richer than bill gates
and second only to jeff bezos most of
elon's worth
is tesla stock and he became the second
richest person
in the world this year because of
tesla's
stratospheric stock gains i mean the
stock is up
more than 500 percent since the start of
the year
as the pandemic chokes the pace of
business for many
tesla says it's on track to deliver half
a million cars in 2020.
tesla's also on track for its first
calendar year of profitability
and just last month the s p announced
that it would add tesla stock to the
index
how has elon musk achieved so much this
year
and at what cost there appears to be no
material impact to tesla and its goals
for 2020 as a result of the pandemic
this
is in part due to elon musk making the
decision to reopen his fremont
california
based car plant before he was given
permission by public health officials
and continue operating there in spite of
the pandemic before defying local orders
to reopen the plant
musk threatened to move operations out
of california because of the
restrictions
but in a cnbc interview governor gavin
newsom didn't seem concerned
i'm also not worried about elon leaving
any time soon i've had a lot of
conversations with him
tesla relies on over 50 000 employees
worldwide
the ones that helped meet musk's
ambitious delivery goals this year
may have faced risks to keep the company
operational
elon musk the ceo of tesla is defying
stay-at-home orders daring authorities
to arrest him
by reopening his california factory
while we don't have
firm numbers from either public health
officials or
from tesla itself we know from various
industry sources that
tesla workers have gotten sick with kova
this year and elon musk
himself did get covered as he tweeted
last month but people got sick in this
frantic push to deliver
a record number of vehicles there's
another reason tesla was able to meet
its 2020 delivery goals
word of thanks to all of our customers
in china
without which tesla would not be here
today this was the first year of
production at the company's shanghai
factory
chinese officials say the government
gave tesla workers ppe
which may have kept production going
during the pandemic
and elon musk and other tesla executives
have told shareholders
that the lower cost of labor there has
greatly helped the company over this
past year
advancements in battery technology also
helped tesla's stock gain
as well as government regulations that
incentivize electric vehicle production
and ownership
batteries are cheaper cars can go longer
on a charge
and there is a broader trend toward
electrification of vehicles being pushed
by consumer demand
and by regulation that we see
particularly in california
tesla's home state which is getting
investors more excited about
opportunities there
four three the u.s government has played
a role in the success of
spacex this year as well i think it's
incredibly important
that government focus on incenting the
outcome not the path
in august spacex won a multi-billion
dollar contract
to become one of the primary satellite
launch providers for the pentagon
in october they won another as part of a
proposed pentagon missile warning system
and a month later nasa partnered with
spacex for the company's first human
operational mission
into space
elon musk has his hand in a bunch of
other projects as well
though none have been as successful as
tesla or spacex
these include you know the boring
company which is all about building
tunnels
underground to solve the problem of
traffic
i mean you can think of these like
wormholes like i need to get to the
other side of
la or new york or whatever drop down the
wormhole pop out the other side
he's also working on a hyperloop project
that uses magnetic levitation
steel tubes and vacuum pumps for ultra
high speed travel
and an ai powered brain implant called
neuralink
in a lot of ways it's kind of like a
fitbit in your skull with tiny wires
which you know neurologists have panned
as made up junk
basically so he has a lot of stuff going
on
um but i would say most of those
projects just seem like they are
decades away from fruition if they're
coming to fruition at all
looking ahead to 2021 musk has doubled
down on some of the promises he made for
2020.
people that really know sales this is a
massive breakthrough he has
promised to deliver on advancements in
battery technology that he unveiled in
september
he has also talked about delivering
possibly a million vehicles
next year and you'll remember his
promise this year was 500
000 vehicles which seemed to stretch and
so these are huge
huge expectations but this year's
successes aside
musk has a history of failing to deliver
on some of his promises
like the long-awaited all-electric
semi-truck trailer he said would come to
market more than a year ago
so if you order now get part the truck
in two years
this is classic elon musk over promising
and under delivering and being way
behind timelines
and if they had launched before the
pandemic
hit they might have had a better
opportunity
given this history analysts and
investors say some of his grand
ambitions for 2021
will likely not be met or at least not
met without setbacks
musk says wednesday's spacex starship
spacecraft test flight
was a success despite the explosive
crash landing
tesla has never really been punished
significantly by wall street
for missing its targets so maybe there
isn't much of a financial downside
for elon musk to make these grand
statements that often
don't come true tesla did not respond to
requests for
out of this comments and so then